hi it's Michelle of lab muffin Beauty
science chemistry PhD and cosmetic
chemist I recently ranked the top
products mentioned in the skincare
addiction subreddit where I used to be a
moderator from 2014 to 2019. a lot of
people asked me to rank the top products
from the Asian beauty subreddit 2 and I
thought this would be interesting
because the list is very different in
Vibe Asian beauty is on Reddit which is
very text-based so there is still a big
focus on what works I think no one likes
to buy products that don't work the
products are still quite budget friendly
from a 2017 survey eighty percent of the
Asian beauty subredders said
affordability influenced their
purchasing but about two-thirds said
they also wanted to experiment with new
and trendy products so the products this
time are I think a bit more interesting
again the actual rankings part is going
to be pretty subjective because I don't
think it is possible to rank anything
without some subjectivity but as always
I will explain my ranks so you can
compare that against your own needs and
wants my scale goes from Holy Grail
which is products I love to death solid
Choice which is stuff I would happily
recommend to my friends and most people
really and then all the way down to not
for anyone maybe for my enemies and
there's also a space for products I
haven't tried myself for long enough to
have an opinion on based on my own
experiences trying to predict how
products are going to go on my skin and
what I've learned over the years looking
into the science of skin care and in my
cosmetic chemistry training you can't
really make acroductions based on just
an ingredients list and it is pretty
misleading when people try to do that as
usual these are my opinions on the
products your skin might not like what
my skin likes as an indication I have
oily skin that gets dehydrated easily
and likes to clog up it likes to produce
a lot of pigment and I live in Sydney
which is pretty humid but as usual
definitely don't stop using a product
you love just because I didn't like it
this time we are going to go from number
20 for extra suspense number 20 is the
cambing mermaid skin gel sunscreen this
is one of only true sunscreens in the
top 20 which I thought was interesting
because sunscreens are one of the most
popular categories of Asian skincare
products but there are a lot of really
popular ones so maybe that diluted
Dimensions Lurie at this website just
counts the number of mentions it doesn't
distinguish between good or bad this is
a Japanese sunscreen and Asian beauty
does generally only cover Japanese and
Korean products the entire top 20 is
just from those two countries there are
obviously a lot more countries in Asia
and some of them have a lot more people
like India Indonesia and China but maybe
because they have so many people their
Beauty Brands don't really tend to focus
on exporting overseas Japan and Korea
tend to do a lot of soft diplomacy where
they try to export their culture
overseas and I think that's why in a
subreddit like Asian beauty which
largely has Western redditors you see
more of these countries products this
has SPF 50 plus and pa4 pluses which is
the highest rating you can get in Japan
It's a combination sunscreen with a mix
of old and new chemical filters as well
as physical filters this used to have a
really fantastic formula it was
lightweight it had barely any white cast
and it wasn't my top sunscreen
recommendations for a long time it's
been through a bunch of changes so I
think first there was new packaging with
the old formula and then they changed
the insides as well and it seems like
the new version does have white cast but
the old version is still stocked in some
places Japanese sunscreens tend to
reformulate and not change their
packaging and most of the info on
Japanese sunscreens and skincare is in
Japanese which makes it a bit harder to
work out what is going on so I think the
reason this is in the top mentions is
because people are confused and asking
questions if this was the old version it
would go straight up to the holy Grails
but for the new version It's either meh
or bad compared to Western sunscreens it
is still pretty good but the confusion
around this does annoy me a lot because
people did buy this off my
recommendation and some of you got a
completely different product I always
feel really bad when people end up with
bad purchases because of me that is why
it takes me so darn long to come out
with review videos I spend weeks testing
the product and days prepping the video
I'm going to put it into bad because
there are so many other sunscreens that
are just less stressful to buy number 19
is the round lab doctor cleanser round
lab is quite a popular brand in Korea
their burst through sunscreen is really
nice I've reviewed that before this
isn't the packaging I have my one has a
little seal on the tube and it has a
little face and it brings me a lot of
Joy which automatically gives a bonus
points for me this is a really nice
cleanser that gives lots of dense foam
but it still has a low PH cleansers that
have like dense luxurious foam are
really popular in Asia and honestly
everywhere because lots of us like foam
when we cleanse and it makes us feel
like it is more cleaning but to get this
texture of foam a lot of Brands will use
soaps of factors that only work at high
ph and this can be an issue if your skin
is acne prone or dehydration prone which
mine is I've been disciplined wanted so
many times by Asian cleansers that have
really lovely foam and then after I use
them for a few weeks my skin ends up dry
and irritated and then I test it and
check the ingredients and it's got soap
surfactants this one uses isothyanate
and toroid which are surfactants that
tend to give the sort of foam texture
but they don't need to be formulated at
high pH having a mix of lots of
different surfactants makes mixed
micelles which are gentler on skin I've
talked about it in my video on cleansing
myths foam on its own doesn't really
tell you much about whether a product is
going to strip your skin or not I don't
know if I would call this the factus
natural they are according to a lot of
natural certification bodies but that's
because their rules are kind of really
arbitrary there's just a list of
chemical reactions that count as natural
for some reason and others are kind of
synthetic I think these certification
bodies just use this as a loophole
because if their brand stuck to truly
natural ingredients they would have like
nothing left this sort of pseudoscience
marketing concepts like clean and the
ewg and natural are getting more and
more popular in Korea there is this
assumption that Korean skincare is
really Innovative and size based but
just like anywhere else people still
fall for cognitive biases this cleanser
also has a whole bunch of really nice
hydrating ingredients like glycerin
hyaluronic acid Alan tone panthenol
ceramides and this compensates for the
stripping that comes from cleansing I
really like this cleanser it's really
gentle and that seal really does bump it
up so I'm going to put it into Holy
Grail and I think this will work for
most people's skin number 18 we have the
cosrx BHA black hair Power Liquid like a
lot of other Korean BHA products this
uses B10 salicylate because of the
regulations around salicylic acid but it
does just split up into salicylic acid
and betame once there's water around and
the amount of salicylic acid versus
salicylate ions just depends on the pH
that the product gets adjusted to at the
end this also has Willy bark water which
is a natural source of salicin that gets
converted into salicylic acid if you eat
it it's a traditional remedy for
headaches but not really if you put it
on your skin this also has niacinamide
which is a really trendy ingredient that
started off getting popular in Asian
skincare products I think the reason
this is so popular is that it was one of
the few salicylic acid products from an
Asian brand for a really long time it
might also be this High because cosrx is
probably the most popular Korean beauty
brand for U.S consumers I personally
didn't see much of a difference when I
used this probably because I use so much
Paula's Choice two percent BHA in
general I would recommend getting
chemical swellings from Western Brands
because it is one of the categories that
is really lacking in Asian skin care I
think this could be an option if you
find Western Products a bit too harsh so
I'm probably going to put this in meh
but let me know if you've have really
good results from this number 17 is the
kosei softimo Speedy cleansing oil
cleansing oils is one of the options you
have for the first step of a double
cleansing routine which is really
popular in Asia this is where you start
off with an oil-based cleanser like a
cleansing oil or a balm and then you
follow up with a water-based cleanser
like a foaming gel double cleansing is a
pretty gentle and effective way to get
rid of waterproof makeup and sunscreen
and this cleansing oil I really enjoy
it's really good value it's really
effective and it's also fragrance free
but it smells neutral so it is really
suitable for a wide range of people
without having that sort of fragrance
free smell I found that this removes
eyeliner well I don't get any icing or
blurriness it has a nice pump which
dispenses an amount that you actually
want there are some really bad pumps out
there my personal gripe with cleansing
oils is just that getting them from my
hand onto my face without anything
dripping on the floor is a bit more
difficult my partner gets really annoyed
about this and oils require a bit more
effort to clean up than water-based
products so I just prefer something more
solid and more portable but yeah there
aren't really no other downsides to this
it is just a solid recommendation I'm
going to put this up into Holy Grail on
to number 16 and I have changed the
lighting background because it is really
hot here and the pink I don't know maybe
it made me feel like I was in hell I
also have an ice pack in my lap because
yeah
Australia this is the kikuma samune
hopefully that is somewhere near the
correct pronunciation high moist lotion
and it is the only body product on this
list it's an Asian lotion which is a
product that has a very liquidy toner
consistency sort of like the runniness
of milk it is really liquid it's not
what you would expect if you come from
like a western skincare background and
you think lotions are thicker creamier
moisturizer products it has a lot of
really interesting ingredients there's a
big focus on pigment targeting and
brightening ingredients like sake
extract which has kojic acid this
product is actually made by a sake
company there's arbutin glizzere which
is a licorice extract there's also
hydrating ingredients like ceramides and
glycerin the smell of this is a little
bit weird to me it starts smelling like
fresh apple cider and then it very
quickly kind of turns into old apple
cider kind of like if you spill some
apple cider on a pub table and left it
for half an hour I found that the smell
went away pretty quickly after about 10
seconds but I can imagine that it might
bother some people it's super hydrating
it can also get a bit onto the sticky
side as you might expect having a pump
with what is basically water in it is a
bit tricky I've seen some people decant
this into a bottle or spray which should
be pretty safe given the ingredients
I've only used it in the pump but I kind
of cut my hand around it to try to you
know catch all the splash I mostly use
this on my body for hydration and maybe
to help tackle some dark marks it is a
lot easier to rub in than like a western
lotion but it might not be quite enough
if you live somewhere very dry I think
if this works on your face it would be
incredible value but some people do say
it breaks them out a bit and that could
potentially be purging it might go away
after your Skin's adjusted I'm going to
put this into solid choice I think it
can be a bit risky with the fragrance
but I think if you don't mind the
fragrance and it works for your face
then it could get bumped up to Holy
Grail number 15 is a repeat that we'll
get to later but number 14 is the COS
Iris low PH clean ends up low PH
cleanses are a selling point in Korean
skincare because a lot of cleansers were
really high pH for a long time and a lot
of them still are this product has been
around for a while and despite the low
PH which is around 5.3 a lot of people
including me still find this really
drying it might be because there aren't
that many surfactants in this so you're
not getting that mix my cell gentle
effect there's also no real hardcore
humectants or moisturizers in the
formula to try to replace what gets
washed away there are some natural
extracts but I think these are mostly
way too water soluble to stay around on
your skin after cleansing I think it is
popular because it's cars RX it's really
easy to get in the U.S and it is really
budget friendly but I think it is worth
it to pay a bit more to get a less
drying cleanser if your skin does get
tight after cleansing I have oily skin
and getting a gentle cleanser has made a
really big difference to how manageable
the oil is plus I think it kind of
balances out because then you save on
hydrating products so I'm going to put
this in there I would recommend the
round lab cleanser over this other
inexpensive options are the Hamish green
foam and the harder labo hyaluronic foam
number 13 is the Biore UV Aqua Rich
watery Essence this is another Japanese
sunscreen it has SPF 50 plus and pa4
pluses as well as some water resistance
this was many people's first Asian
sunscreen kind of like their Gateway
sunscreen and it shows up a lot in my
top sunscreen recommendations it has a
lot of the features that Asian
sunscreens are really known for it's
really lightweight and it feels
refreshing to apply which is a really
stuck contrast from Western sunscreens
this sits really nicely under makeup and
it contains some of those newer filters
that give better UVA protection as well
as that light texture this does contain
alcohol but it's not a big problem for
most people because it also has
moisturizing ingredients that counteract
that effect this has a mild floral scent
and it's easily available and not very
expensive although you do need to watch
out for fakes on Amazon and eBay overall
this is great but I do feel a little bit
hesitant to put it into the holy Grails
because it does get reformulated quite
frequently about every two years the
newest 2023 version has just come out
which I haven't quite tried yet but all
of the formulations I've tried which is
about three or four of them have been
great so I think it is pretty safe to
Chuck it into holy Grails number 12 is
the chewed house Soon Jung Emulsion I
haven't tried this but I do want to try
it there is another product from this
range coming up so this is going into
the no opinion number 11 is the isn't
tree green tea fresh toner this is a
toner that's based on green tea and some
other plant extracts these all have
antioxidant benefits I tried this for
about a week which isn't really long
enough to give it a thorough review but
I have had Turners through a lot more
for my skin in that amount of time this
is very lightly hydrating and there are
reviews from people who have said that
it helps reduce their oil over time in
general I've personally found that green
tea is a pretty underwhelming ingredient
on my skin and I think I'm just not that
much of a toner person I am a bit of a
minimalist with my routine so toners
that don't give that much of a hydrating
effect are pretty much one of the first
products to go it is really affordable
though so I'm gonna put it in math for
now I am open to being convinced let me
know in the comments how you found this
if you've tried it number 10 is the I'm
from Rice toner and that is not the
correct product image the iPhone range
has a bunch of star ingredients that are
trending in Asian skin care and this one
is from the rice range it also has
niacinamide and adenosine which is a
combo I've seen in a lot of Korean
skincare products and the reason for
this I think is because it allows them
to be marketed as anti-aging functional
Cosmetics this is really nice and light
I did find that it had a little bit of a
brightening effect on me but I preferred
the cream from this range the iPhone
rice cream has this really lovely
texture that works really nicely under
makeup it is under my makeup right now
and again I think I'm just not that much
of a toner person it is on the pricier
end for a toner and some people do have
issues with rice extract so so I'm going
to put this in
me or solid choice I don't know
I'm gonna put it in solid choice if it
was cheaper it would definitely be in
solid Choice number nine is the attitude
house Soon Jung two times barrier
intensive cream this line is formulated
with panthenol and Magic Castle side
which is from centella extract it's the
same combination of ingredients that you
see in the La Roche per se sickle plus
bomb B5 which is a cult product one of
my favorite products for soothing and
dealing with irritated unhappy skin
people seem to have mixed experiences
with this product some people love it
and swear by it and some it just didn't
really work well for for me I found that
it didn't work as well as Sega Plus for
things like treasure no appealing and
irritation it feels like it kind of just
sits on top of my skin and it doesn't
really go down and hydrate as well as I
would like it also has this really
interesting twist lock dispenser you
flip it open and then you have to twist
the cap to let the product come out of
what looks like a Mercedes-Benz symbol
it's really cool and different but at
the same time it makes it really
difficult to to dispense a little bit
and the tube itself is quite small so I
went through this really quickly much
faster than I did with a sickle plus
bomb tube some people with dry skin have
complained that it wasn't as
moisturizing as they hurt but it does
seem to work really well for people who
have really easily irritated skin I
think one of the other products in the
lime might work better for my skin so
maybe the Emulsion or they have a hydro
Barrier cream and I think those ones
would deliver more hydration which is
what I am after they also have a bomb
product that seems to be a lot heavier
but it's more like a targeted spot
treatment I am so sorry to the people
who love it but I'm going to put it to
meh for people in general because I
think there are moisturizers with much
higher satisfaction rates but if you
think this might work for you I would
definitely recommend trying out a sample
because you might be one of the lucky
ones if this does work for you let me
know in the comments what your skin type
your climate what other moisturizers you
like are and maybe we can narrow down
who this works really well for number 8
is that I'm from mugwort Essence I
haven't tried this for long enough to
have a real opinion it is 100 mug water
extract which is Artemisia princeps
magwood is a herb that's getting more
popular in Korean skincare it's kind of
like the new centella it seems to be
good for redness and breakouts this
product is a bit on the pricey side but
it has really good reviews from people
who like mugwort number seven is the
harder labo premium lotion this is a
classic super hydrating hyaluronic acid
tonal or Essence again that word lotion
in Asian skincare isn't really what we
think of as a lotion in Western skincare
but this is starting to change because I
think Asian brands are starting to
realize there is this confusion this has
lots of different forms of hyaluronic
acid and I find that in general products
that have lots of different sizes of ha
tend to give more well-rounded hydration
at different depths of your upper layer
of skin it kind of gives longer lasting
hydration so some of the smaller bits
can go into your skin and hydrate deeper
some of the bigger bits can sit more on
top and hatch water as it tries to leave
this product has been a staple for a
really long time in Reddit skincare
communities from when I first started
really getting into Reddit skincare in
like 2013 it's really inexpensive it
comes in a large bottle one time I tried
to buy a bottle during a stopover in
Malaysia but it exceeded my liquid limit
and that was like the one time
terrorists have really ruined my way of
life I'm going to put this into solid
choice and I think this is again my bias
against toners that don't do much except
for hydrate it is really hydrating but
these days there are tons of toners that
hydrate as well as doing other things
too so yeah that's going to sit there
and number six is the COS RX propolis
toner speaking of toners that hydrate
and do other things this is one of them
propolis is really popular in Korean
skincare it's basically like the B glue
that they use to stick their hives
together it has a lot of antioxidant and
anti-inflammatory effects and it's been
investigated for wound healing my
impression of propolis for a long time
was that it was mostly targeted at acne
prone skin so I didn't try for ages I've
been converted though propolis has been
really nice for smoothing out my skin
without any sort of irritation I have
pollen allergies so I've been a bit
hesitant about bee products but all the
ones I've tried from Asian skincare
brands have been really soothing this
toner is really light a lot lighter than
other propolis products like the skin
food and Rich Essence and yeah you can
see all of the hydrating and soothing
ingredients there there's honey glycerin
butane hyaluronic acid and panthenol you
do need to use a bit more product than
like the skin food and Rich Essence but
this is really budget friendly I think
this might actually maybe Holy Grail
sell the choice of Holy Grail
oh I'm gonna put it into solid choice
because I haven't really tried it for
long enough but I think there's a good
chance once I try it for longer it's
going to jump up into Holy Grail number
five is the Laneige cream skin refiner
this is a really lovely moisturizer it's
kind of like they say a cream that's
been turned into a liquid it's a
relatively unique product it's one of my
friend Hannah english's favorite
products for irritated skin she has dry
skin it works well for me too in Winter
and I have relatively oily skin and it
also comes as a convenient Mist so you
can just spray it over your makeup for
example it has the same ingredients list
but I'm not sure if it is maybe a
slightly watered down version It's a
relatively short ingredients list for an
Emulsion which has a lot of oil as well
as water-based ingredients there's no
fragrance there's no niacinamide which
makes this a bit of a rarity I think but
if you do like niacinamide and fragrance
there is a copycat product from Hamish
which has those I'm going to put this
into solid Choice especially if you have
dry skin or if you want what's pretty
much a moisture that you can spray on
your face over makeup number four is the
pun Kang your essence toner I actually
reviewed this recently it was included
in gothamist's favorite products a few
years back it's a really inexpensive
toner but it's not really a one step
toner it's not really hydrating it is
based on plant extracts and I think this
could be a nice really lightly hydrating
toner in summer this is hovering between
solid choice and math for me I think it
is probably a solid choice if you like
doing lots of layers of toner a lot of
people love this for the seven skins
method it's really lightweight and it is
really inexpensive despite it looking
pretty premium whoever designed this
ranking system needed to have more
granularity in it they really didn't
think this through number three is the
iliune ceramide ATO concentrate cream
okay I need to do some complaining this
has two of my product X first off it
says seven free right on the front of
the tube so if you've been here for long
enough if you've watched enough of my
content you probably know how much I
hate 8 free from clean Beauty marketing
because it's based on pseudoscience you
probably want me to just skip over this
and move on but here is why I keep
mentioning it Brand's putting it on the
front of their packaging is a calculated
move they figured that this will bring
in more customers than it puts off so if
people like me aren't vocal about the
fact that it is off-putting then more
Brands will keep doing it because they
don't see the downside but the problem
is that less educated consumers will
come across Brands doing this and assume
that there is some sort of legitimate
benefit the presence of this label acts
as consumer education it isn't like a
neutral harmless thing customers will
ask Brands who don't have this label if
they're also seven free and more and
more Brands will be pressured into
putting this on their labels without any
sort of pushback so I feel a
responsibility to kind of be part of the
pushback and try to reduce this
seemingly benign but actually quite
Insidious misinformation the other ick
is this has like little bursting beads
in it they're like these white granules
inside the product they kind of give
this illusion of the product having
concentrated ingredients like these
other actives and you can actually see
them in a few products these beads are
there to keep ingredients stable but I'm
always worried that they won't mash up
properly and I'll just be walking around
with dots on my face for this product
they do seem to blend in reasonably
easily and I use them mostly at night so
it is mostly okay this product was
reformulated at the end of 2021 and it
might be highly mentioned because of
that again lots of people are discussing
it there's a lot of mixed reviews on
whether the old version or the new
version are better or if there's even
any difference the bees seem to be
larger in the old version and the old
version also seem to be a bit lumpier
and less thick to me the moisturizing
properties of this are quite similar to
the attitude how soon junk berry cream
but there's no panthenol on my decaster
side so it's not really as targeted for
barrier repair I found that this didn't
really do enough to hydrate my skin
there's not much of an occlusive or
humectant effect even though glycerin is
near the top of the ingredient list I
found that I needed to really hydrate my
skin underneath and that could make
sense because most Asian skincare
routines would have that step but it is
a pretty bland product and it sinks into
skin nicely so it could be good if your
skin is really irritated I think it's
quite interesting that this cream and
the sunjun cream both seem to lack
occlusiveness and I'm wondering if it
might be because petrolatum and mineral
oil aren't really that common in Korean
products I've been seeing these a lot
more in free from lists than in the
actual ingredient list and a lot of
Korean products seem to Pride themselves
on not using them they really go on
about how they only have green grade ewg
products but petrolatum and mineral oil
are just really really good occluses it
is relatively difficult to make a long
lasting overnight moisturizer without
using them this isn't a giant path
though and it is reasonably cheap so I'm
gonna put this into I think solid choice
although I am tempted to dock mask for
that seven free because I am really
annoyed at that I'm gonna be Petty today
number two is the cause RX now mucine
Essence this was the product that was
also at number 15 and it looks like if
luria combined all those mentions this
would end up as number one this is the
one product that was on both the
skincare addiction and the Asian beauty
top 20 it was number 10 on that one the
next Asian skincare product in the sea
list is at number 27. I've talked about
this product a lot recently there are
lots of reasons why I think it is
mentioned so much first off snail slime
is exotic and it plays into this whole
idea of like mystical Asian skincare
secrets so it is just a really kind of
gimmicky product although it actually
works really well for a lot of people it
packs this really huge hydrating punch
which is really good for a glowy glass
skin look it also has a really fun sort
of stringy texture it looks good in
videos and it trended on Tick Tock plus
again class RX is really budget friendly
and easy to find I really love this
product it is super hydrating and even
though it does seem a bit gimmicky it
has been a staple in a lot of people's
skincare routines for a long time it
does break some people out with closed
comedones but otherwise it is really
good I'm going to put this up in holy
Grails I think it has stood the test of
time it's just a product that seems to
work really well for a lot of people's
skin finally we have product number one
which is drum roll
the Milano CC Essence I'm really happy
with this at number one it was also the
one that was on number 27 in the sca
list this is a vitamin C product with
ascorbic acid and the main thing that is
super cool about this is actually the
packaging the packaging is this really
clever airtight dispenser that limits
oxidation really effectively Like Oxygen
just cannot get into this thing you
actually have to squeeze this really
hard for just like one drop to come out
I have a tube that I opened around
probably January 2021 and now more than
two years later there is dried up brown
stuff on like the thread of the cap but
if you squeeze it the stuff that comes
out is still completely colorless it is
just mind-blowing this is marketed as an
anti-acne product in Japan it has a
bunch of ingredients like potassium
glycerate which is the active ingredient
in licorice it's anti-inflammatory as
well as isopropyl methylphenol which is
antibacterial as well as that cool
packaging keeping it stable for ages it
has a delivery system that helps the
ingredients straight deeper it's based
on glycol it has a really different
texture from a lot of vitamin C products
though it's got this sort of really
thick draggy oil like texture but it
does sink in pretty quick it feels a lot
like an oil I found this really
non-irritating it has a really light
scent and on my skin it worked really
well to even out skin tone from shallow
pigment for me that's mostly when I have
post-inflammatory hyperpigmentation
after a pimple heals and that is the
main reason I use vitamin C so I think
this is just a really cool and unique
product it is fantastic for people who
don't use vitamin C that much and you
need something that will last like a
decade and yes I am planning to keep
this tube for as long as possible so ask
me in I don't know 2031 what this looks
like so that is going into the holy
Grails so overall I think these products
are a lot more diverse than the ones we
saw from skincare addiction that had
lots of fragrance free products lots of
simple cleanses and moisturizers and a
handful of single ingredient products
this of products have a lot more
different active ingredients and there
are a bit more controversial products
that have mixed opinions on them and I
think that's because Asian beauty tends
to have a bit more discussion there's
more I guess Advanced skincare uses
there people want to explore stuff so
with skincare addiction we had a lot
more solid Choice products because
everything was just pretty inoffensive
but these ones I think are a lot more
interesting there's a lot more in the
mayor tier for reasons that are quite
unique to Me overall here there are 13
products from Korea and six from Japan
and the Japanese products are all sort
of older Legacy products that started
being popular a long time ago the newest
one is probably from like 2015. at the
moment Korean products are a lot more
popular and there are a lot of new ones
here although there are still lots of
sort of Legacy products I think that's
because Korean products just tend to be
cheaper on the whole and there is also a
lot of support from the Korean
government for Beauty Brands to export
their products again that is that soft
diplomacy thing the Korean government is
actually sponsoring beauty stores to
export products which is kind of
mind-blowing I I cannot imagine the
Australian government doing that so it's
a lot easier for Western registers to
buy Korean products plus there is a lot
more information in English compared to
for Japanese products let me know what
you thought of these products what you
thought of my rankings please don't be
too mad at me these are subjective
please let me know if there's a way of
using some of these products that I just
don't know about that might change my
rankings you can also check out my
rankings of the skincare addiction
products and I have some Korean skincare
reviews that I've done recently as well
I hope you enjoyed this chatty video and
I am going to run off and do sweat now